Michael
are you having money problems monkey
problems now I'm not having monkey
problems why would I have monkey
problems
how can I get you to stay money yeah
we all want money
but there is none on the budget so
tell me why you're really leaving money
More Money More Problems Stanley you of
all people should know that let me ask
you this
if I were money okay Michael here's the
15 I owe you no thank you yeah I heard
you might need it so
here's the Forty hours you gave me I
didn't give you forty dollars
in a way you did
you guys are looking for cash for the
wedding yeah I mean if it's all the same
for you question for you would you guys
rather have a hundred dollars now or
five thousand dollars a year from now a
hundred dollars now for sure because you
just give me fifty dollars to cover the
broker fee I put in 100 of my own money
as the gift yeah no no I'll um the 100
I'll just take the hundred
instead of five thousand dollars a year
from now
sure is this
the guy has an algorithm to determine
the winner of Any Given college
basketball game
don't tell Jim
Hey cuz
you're having money problems no you
didn't listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy all your problems go
away Creed Braden has never declared
bankruptcy when Creed Bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Schneider
how would that help Creed in Monopoly
you go bankrupt you lose you don't go by
Monopoly man that game is nuts nobody
just picks up get out of jail free cards
those things cost thousands
that is a good point bankruptcy Michael
is Nature's do-over it's a fresh start
it's a clean slate Ortho Witness
Protection Program not at all
I've always wanted to be in the witness
protection program
Fresh Start no debts no baggage
already got my name picked out
Lord Rupert Everton
I'm a uh a shipping Merchant who raises
fancy dogs
that's the life
I declare
bankruptcy
how much can we afford to pay a delivery
guy well if these numbers you gave me
are correct they are correct sir then
you can't afford to pay them anything
okay
a lame attempt at humor swinging a miss
your prices are too low lowest in town
why do you think Staples and vendor
Mifflin can't match your prices
corporate greed look our pricing model
is fine I reviewed the numbers myself
over time with enough volume we become
profitable yeah with a fixed cost
pricing model that's correct yeah but
you need to use a variable cost pricing
model okay sure right so why don't you
explain what that is so they can under
yeah just explain what that is explain
what you think that is okay just explain
that as you sell more paper and your
company grows solely your costs for
example Delivery Man health care
business expansion whatever yeah so at
these prices the more paper you sell the
less money you'll make our prices are
the only thing keeping us in business
they're actually putting you out of
business
okay okay hold on hold on
Ty I would like you to Crunch those
numbers again
the program there's no such thing just
crunch them just crunch them please
crunch
did it help
hey guys
Jen is ready for you
bring it home now and don't forget the
new black man phrase I touch Bippity
poppy give me the zombie yes sir
remember that
I'll be right outside if you need me all
right
yeah top Mike some new phrases
I want them to get the razor
just can't help myself
what's wrong with you
it was a weird day
I accidentally cross-dressed
and then Daryl made me feel bad for not
making any money
and then I had to ride up here with
stupid Toby and then your assistant was
all young and hot and I okay Michael
I can offer you a 12 raise but
you have got to ask for 15.
that's ridiculous I'm never gonna just
I just need you to ask for it so I can
record that you asked for it
okay
ah so
all right Levinson
here's the rub
I would like a 15 raise no but we can
offer you 12. but you just said 15.
oh hey there you go oh man it was great
they were great did you end up investing
I did yeah how much
um yeah by then I guess it was
about 10
about ten ten there's a full 10.
wow yeah
it's a good thing we talked about it
though because we had to yeah yeah
and everybody did everybody end up
investing ten thousand um
they weren't really talking that much
about money they just said we're good
with investing and then ladies and
gentlemen
Here Comes
travel
they were done with the investing and
then you volunteered ten thousand
dollars
so you invested ten thousand dollars to
look like a team player
[Applause]
greatest fan of your life
wait wait hold on where's the band
because there's no way you guys are
making this magic with just your mouths
[Music]
foreign
I just wanted you to know that you can't
just say the word bankruptcy and expect
anything to happen I didn't say it I
declared it still that's
not anything
this is a lot of credit card debt yeah
tell me about it you know Shannon is my
credit cards and she's
using them as if I made him money she
thinks I'm a human ATM machine
okay 125 Amazon
oh best The Muppet Show on DVD classic
twelve hundred dollars what's a core
Blaster extreme that is by far the best
way to strengthen your core this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist and you
twist it strengthens your entire core
your back core your arm core
your
the Marine Corps actually uses it I
think that's how they got core I was
working in finance and I got involved in
some Insider training so I spent a
little time in the clink
that is awesome
I had Martin explain to me three times
what he got arrested for because
sounds an awful lot like what I do here
every
I've been involved in a number of Cults
both as a leader and a follower he had
more fun as a follower but you make more
money as a leader
I'm sorry I'm so sorry you lied to us
I lied to myself too
I'm not a millionaire
I thought I would be by the time I was
30 but I wasn't even close and then I
thought maybe by the time I was 40 but
by 40 I had less money than when I was
30. maybe by my 50s I don't know